أثناء صنع هذا التقليد الضخم
لعائلتي وجميع أسلافي أشعر أن
هذا كان أسلوب حياتهم بالنسبة لنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذه القصة العظيمة من
إدارة جورجيا الوطنية للسياحة
ويعود تاريخ صناعة النبيذ في جورجيا تقريبًا
ثمانية آلاف سنة في الواقع وفقًا
للأكاديمية الوطنية للعلوم ،
فقد ثبت أن هذا البلد كان
مسقط رأس النبيذ مع أكثر من 40
مزرعة عنب ، ولا يزال تقليد صناعة النبيذ
قويًا اليوم ، ولكن ما يجعل
النبيذ الجورجي مختلفًا تمامًا في
أسلوب صنع النبيذ الجورجي هو الأقدم في
العالم كله
بدأ منذ 8000 عام ، اسمي بوب
واتسون وأنا صانع النبيذ النبيذ الجورجي
مختلف حقًا أولاً عن
أصناف العنب الفريدة والمحلية
الموجودة في بلدنا ، يوجد 525 نوعًا أصليًا
في جورجيا نستخدمه في حوالي
25 قبرًا  الإنتاج الضخم
والسبب الثاني
لامتلاكنا لطريقة صنع النبيذ المختلفة هذه الطريقة الفريدة
هي تخمير النبيذ
بجلود العنب  وأيضًا إطار استعلام صناعة النبيذ ،
هذه الدوائر الموجودة على الأرض هي
قمم ربما تلك الأواني الفخارية الضخمة
التي تم دفنها بالداخل وهي
تجعلها رائعة بسبب
التحكم في درجة الحرارة للأذن بأكملها
بالداخل لا نستخدم التقنيات الحديثة
أو  الثلاجات
مستقرة لأنها موضوعة في الأرض ،
لذا فهي الطبيعة الأم المثالية
لنبيذ رائع ونادر حقًا في
العالم
تمتلك جورجيا قدرًا هائلاً من
كرم الضيافة الذي ينطوي على الدم ، وهذا يعني الكثير
بالنسبة لنا أن نستقبل ضيوفًا لنا.
من المهم حقًا الحفاظ على
أساليب صناعة النبيذ التقليدية
لأننا إذا لم نفعل ذلك ، فلن يقوم أحد بذلك
في المستقبل القريب ، فنحن نريد أن نمنح هذا
المذاق الفريد للأجيال
والأجيال بعد ذلك
[موسيقى]